being your own artist instead of an
imitation of what your teachers might
have instilled in you can we talk about
that oh yeah we can I think that is the
final launch
to really being able to allow yourself
to achieve your dreams at some point you
can't be a student anymore you have to
just kind of blindly charge at it the
way you would want to I actually find
that to be a big trap for
folks in our industry people who get too
comfortable with the student mentality
you know people like at least on the
after side of things people who stay
with the same studio for like 15 years
and I'm like you know
think you learned what they have to
teach but I get it I mean it's hard when
you find a community but at some point
you need to strike out and do it your
way because at the end of the day when
you think of artists that have made an
impact sort of across Fields whether it
be
the visual arts or film or music or what
have you they always end up leaving
the herd and doing it their way when you
think of like Harrison Ford or Tom Hanks
they're just them you know I I know if
I'm gonna see something with Harrison
Ford in it like I kind of know what's
coming he's going to be Harrison Ford
he's never put himself ever in a
position where he's not so
when I teach
my students or when I Mentor folks it's
always from from day one it's always
about
what do you want to do what speaks to
you how about you bring the material in
that you think is interesting and
exciting let's go from there hey why
don't we build a project off of that
material oh is this your calling that's
fun like I I want to find what lights
them up and go from there and that's how
I also steer my own career is like
you know if I can't make a choice
whether it be something as in front ever
behind the camera
I can survey my mentors I can talk to
teachers I can coach all day long but at
the end of the day I have to make a
decision
and that decision is going to be made
off of my own gut instincts I might be
looking for reinforcement from other
people but at some point you have to
have the courage to fail forward
I also just believe that if you're
making a decision from a place that
isn't ego driven and that is just your
own artistic self it's going to be
really hard to fail but if you do fail
it's going to actually be a learning
experience where you're going to be able
to be more honed in to what you need to
do better next time you have to be
willing to make that leap at the end of
the day
how do we learn from a teacher
without making them a quote unquote Guru
and then if we leave the quote unquote
Nest then we can bring a little bit of
our own Flair to it
yeah you know
I don't know that there is a way to not
make somebody a guru in that that's
their choice you know I've worked with
teachers where it's like gather around
me my students and it's like well you um
you chose that and I can't tell you to
not choose that for me it's just like
knowing that quite frankly that is a
marketing trick and there are a lot of
teachers who are making this town and in
other towns are making money by showing
their students I am a guru and you don't
know anything whether it's a
conservatory or a private Studio or just
like a random online class that is how
people make money so I am aware of that
and sensitive to that marketing and I go
in and go well what can I learn and when
I feel like I'm starting to butt head
that's when I it's funny because one of
my best friends pointed that out to me
she was like you know at some point you
start butting heads with them and that's
when you're ready to go and I'm like
yeah yeah this is a pretty solid read
actually when my own ethos and ethics
like get in the way that's when it's
like you know what I think I actually
have learned what I need and I'm already
ready to do this on my own so I'm just
gonna go do it my way
um I think you just for for everybody
out there listening you have to be
really conscientious about
going in there don't assume that you
don't know anything like you're a person
who has a lived experience you know
things whether or not the teacher thinks
you know anything is irrelevant it's
ultimately your decision as to how much
of a student versus artist you already
are so I think it's just about going in
like being really dispassionate not
buying Into The Branding that you're
getting shoved at in your face and being
like what can I learn here what's fun
then take it home and like try it on
yourself play with it yourself see how
it feels
and then keep working with them until
you're not really getting anything out
of it is what I would say and then move
on and very often what it means is that
you've kind of Almost Up leveled where
it's like okay I need to find someone
who plays at this level now who plays at
this level who's who's going to be able
to deliver what I need for where I'm at
as an artist and at some point you're
not going to find that anymore that all
comes from you and I think if you go
into classes like that you start to
develop your own system for
self-teaching
and I find it's the people who
self-teach that really succeed
as you mentioned earlier it's funny you
were mentioning Tom Hanks I was actually
thinking around that time of the Tom
Hanks character uh in Forrest Gump where
he's jogging and and all these followers
are behind him yeah and then he stops
and they're like hey guys okay wait he's
stopping he's stopping he's gonna speak
he's gonna speak and all he says is I'm
tired now and so you're like why were
they following him because some people
they we all kind of want someone to
follow yeah it's I think it's probably
Human Nature
I'm weird and that I don't like I I get
a little stifled when I feel like
there's something that I have to follow
and I think in the past that energy has
really triggered some folks who are not
secure with their own state of identity
and internal leadership which I'm like
I'm sorry that you feel upset by me
existing I'm not going to change
anything
um but yeah I think I think that there
are a lot of folks where it is human
nature to be able to want to follow
someone
look at social media that's literally
what it is is following people but I
mean at the end at the end of the day
you only live once and and not trying to
Yellow this but um
but I mean it's like do you want to live
as yourself you know when when you're
old and you're dying
um do you want to live as yourself or do
you want to be like wow that was a waste
of time I actually side note have
legally died before and it completely
changed my entire life perspective and I
think that's why I now sound Airy fairy
I love that and I'm stealing that um
Airy fairy is my new favorite phrase but
uh it changed everything for me because
it's like well okay that happened like
that is going to happen again at some
point so I'm gonna make the most of the
time that I have
rather than try to delude myself into
thinking that I'm an immortal being
and so I want to live as myself I want
to live in alignment with my values I
think that too many folks are
blinded by the sort of consumerist
principles that were taught as kids I
mean literally taught right like
indoctrinated into brands from a little
kid I sound like a rampant communist I
am just a person who notices things and
I I'm very nerdy about branding just
gonna say that right now but we really
are indoctrinated to things like
McDonald's or other brands that are like
household names you're a child this is
normal
and it's almost like we're taught to
Value those Brands more than we are
taught to be still and start to discover
what our own value systems are because I
really believe that if you know who you
are you know what you believe in you
know what you stand for and you live in
accordance with that you're going to
live a life filled with purpose that is
aligned with your true calling as it
were so that when your time has come and
it's time to leave this planet you can
say yeah I'm happy with what I did
and sharing only what you want to share
about it you said having yeah it's a
weird experience yeah I'm totally
comfortable talking about it so uh what
changed afterwards was it a gradual
changing this is pretty immediate
um
well I guess I knew what happened like I
can concretely say cool I know what's
going to happen when I die
um which took the fear out of it so then
it was like okay
Paradigm switch it's not about being
afraid of death like I can't stop it
it's going to come at some point it's
just use use the time that I have now
don't take it for granted with the
caveat of like mental health happens and
sometimes you really don't feel great
and then it's like be kind to yourself
please but in terms of now it's just
I'm gonna work really hard every day and
if I don't feel good I will take care of
myself and then proceed to work really
hard with the time I have
did you change any
um life habits in terms of maybe being
on the fence about a career before and
then knowing this is what I meant to do
get that changed it's like all of a
sudden I wasn't scared anymore of a lot
of stuff I was just like nothing is
altogether alarming and if anything it
kind of evened out the playing field
like we all will die every person
watching this I'm sorry to report you
will die one day we're all gonna die and
that means that I am the same as Tom
Cruise
we are the same as a houseless person
that I have yet the pleasure of meeting
we are all the image the great equalizer
and we all have the same gift of being
here on this planet we all have the gift
of time we may not all have access or
privilege to be able to do what we want
I will not deny that I'm very fortunate
in the life that I was randomly born
into but that doesn't change that we
have undeniable things like time to be
able to work towards what it is that we
ultimately want